good morning John it's Friday I think
and I wanted to show you something real
quick because I discovered it in it's
very fun and it's taped to a copy of my
album so joking
let me do that again for you sunshine
you're going to power the earth someday
campaign to trying to highlight the fact
that they are working in renewable
energy which they are and this
technology the augmented reality if I
taped a thing to my album and now I'm
holding the 3d hologram in my hand thing
can't really see that that's going to
save the world but solar panels solar
panels will save the world and General
Electric is doing the thing you can
solar and wind hold on a second
left-right wind so this was fun to mess
with and if you want to do it yourself
you can all you need is a printer and a
webcam and it's a plug into this mark
grid comm and there's a little scarecrow
here and make more sense if you watch
the Super Bowl ads and that is all they
did not pay me to do this for those of
you who are curious about that it's just
something I thought was really fun and
interesting and since I do video I
figured I would show this to you okay